[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
did larry king purposely write his
estranged wife out of his will before
his death
a louisiana inmate convicted of
attempting to rape two 14 year old girls
in 1977 claims new evidence could
exonerate him
these are things that
no one has ever had before charges drop
for the so-called central part karen
after amy cooper completes a counseling
program plus
a son testifies about his mother's
disappearance and presumed death
she's my best friend as well as my
mother
was victoria prokopovic murdered by her
own husband
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
wife of legendary tv host larry king is
reportedly planning to contest his will
in court larry king died on january 23
at the age of 87. according to reports
king filed a handwritten amendment to
his will
in october 2019 leading his 2 million
estate to his five children
the note excluded his wife of 22 years
sean king
the couple had filed for divorce just
months earlier and were estranged
tragically two of king's adult children
died within three weeks of each other
last year sean king now wants to take
her claims to court telling the new york
post page six
that they drew up an estate plan
together in 2015
and believe someone might have pressured
him to write the amendment
she also claims the two recently became
reconnected talking every day before his
passing
king was interviewed by law and crime
host jesse weber in 2018.
i try to ask good questions and elicit
good answers
the number one thing in interviewing is
listening
you have to listen and you have to be
able to respond to what they've said
take it all in it's so wonderful it
beats work
terry amended will months after a
divorce kind of makes sense i think most
of us but
how the will was done or amended that
could be the issue right
well it's absolutely an issue if you
have a will
that in 2015 was typed out it was
witnessed it was executed and then you
do a handwritten
amendment that's not good enough it
would be one thing
if he tore up the original will and
completely changed it in handwriting
but this little handwritten amendment i
don't think is going to prevail and i
think
just equitably she has a good claim
because she basically
you know supported him all this time and
contributed to his businesses
yeah of course we'll keep an eye on that
looking at the form of how that
amendment was done was it certified
did someone observe it as a witness all
things that have to be answered thank
you very much terry
now to louisiana where an inmate says he
was convicted
decades ago of trying to rape two
sisters based on a lie
and he wants the prosecutor removed from
the case angenette levy is here with
vincent simmons story
yeah brian vincent simmons is he's
serving a 100-year prison sentence for
the attempted
aggravated rape of twin sisters he says
he is innocent and the victim
of racism and people who lied to put him
in prison
this is a lie attorney justin bonus
represents vincent simmons who's been in
prison for nearly 45 years for the
attempted aggravated rapes of 14 year
old twin sisters
vincent didn't get any discovery really
of
substance in 1977 so he tried this case
with his lawyers blindly simmons's case
has been featured in three documentaries
including the 1999 film the farm angola
usa
in which the sanders sisters testified
at a parole hearing
in the past 20 years the only
country that we've had was to know that
he could not hurt
us or our family or someone else you
committed these two rapes
bonus has filed this 346-page motion
that includes exhibits
he outlines why he believes simmons is
innocent it includes photos from a
police lineup
bonus says was faulty because it showed
simmons in handcuffs
if their id is wrong then it
vincent didn't do this right this is a
stranger identification they didn't know
him
meanwhile simmons says a man named keith
labord a cousin of the sanders sisters
admitted to a family member that he
actually had consensual sex with one of
the girls
and lied at trial the board name if you
understand it in louisiana
is is these are very this is a a
prominent family there's many many many
many la boards
attorney justice justin bonus claims
that the prosecutor in the case actually
told someone in the community
that the evidence for simmons to
represent himself properly at trial was
not turned over
but that prosecutor charles riddle said
in a court filing that that's not the
case he didn't say that
and that simmons's new claims of new
evidence
are not actually new at all that he's
raised all of these issues before
that prosecutor riddle was expected to
testify at a hearing this week
but that hearing is expected to be
postponed because of a big snowstorm
that hit the area brian thanks angenet
joining us to help break down this case
is criminal defense attorney eklund
mercy and terry austin
eckland brady violations how bad are
they and how much could they affect this
case
oh my god a brady violation is like a
draw for
of all trump like criminal trials if you
have a brady violation
and it's one it's a substantial one it's
a problem
the issue is we have these uh
prosecutors who go
rogue and especially if you have a pro
state even if you have a pro se
defendant
you have to give all your evidence you
have the
you have all the cards you have to get
it's constitutional
you have to give all the evidence and
then we have these prosecutors who are
all about catching this one defendant
and they're not really doing their jobs
which is
being ministers of justice for all
including
the defendant so um yeah yeah now terry
in order thanks to
equine in order to get to that point
though there's got to be some sort of
hearing like angenette
mentioned where the prosecutor could
actually take the stand how do you see
that playing out
well you know in a brady hearing if the
prosecution does take the stand that's
the last place you want to be you don't
want to be
on a witness stand trying to defend your
actions trying to explain
whether or not you did provide all of
the necessary information so
hopefully the hearing will go well for
him and if not maybe
he will have to recuse himself from the
case now angenette what do the sanders
sister and keith labord
uh say about this well uh brian that's
funny you mentioned that because i
actually contacted both of the sanders
sisters they have not
returned my messages so far but they
have stood by their story
in the past and i also called keith
laborde's home today
and a man answered the phone he actually
said that he was a friend of keith
labored and wouldn't let me speak with
la board
uh this gentleman said that that vincent
simmons is guilty
and that he should hang he said all
kinds of uh kind of
things saying that he believed he was
guilty but he would not do an interview
with me
and he would not let me speak with keith
aboard all right so it's gonna be
interesting the next thing and jeanette
real quickly
we're gonna wait for this hearing where
those prosecutors take the stand is that
the next step in this case to seeing how
it unravels
yeah i mean we have to wait and see what
happens because
the hearing is going to be postponed
because of this big snowstorm that hit
the area they can't transfer
or transport vincent simmons from the
prison to the courthouse because of the
snowstorm they're not used to getting
this much snow there so we really have
to wait and see what happens the
prosecutor is maintaining
that he didn't do anything wrong in the
case so it'll be interesting to see what
happened
all right make sure to keep eyes on that
case thank you for the update all
still ahead on law and crime daily a
former nfl player
suddenly found dead in a florida hotel
room plus
another former football player is
speaking out after his arrest
the case of vincent jackson and adam
pakman jones after the break
[Music]
investigators in florida are looking
into the death of a former nfl player
found deceased in a hotel room
according to the hillsborough county
sheriff's office 38-year-old vincent
jackson was found dead
monday around 11 30 a.m jackson played
12 seasons in the nfl
his last five for the tampa bay
buccaneers the sheriff's office says he
had checked into the hotel
on january 11 and his family reported
him as missing
last week deputies conducted a welfare
check on february 12
and confirmed his well-being no apparent
signs of trauma were reported
the county medical examiner's office is
conducting an autopsy
and another former nfl player is
speaking out after their arrest
adam pakman jones was arrested for
misdemeanor assault
monday in cincinnati ohio jones is
accused of punching and kicking a
bouncer at a club
in the head until they were unconscious
he's had several past run-ins with the
law
including disorderly conduct charges and
pleading guilty to cheating at gambling
jones played for the cincinnati bengals
denver broncos
dallas cowboys and tennessee titans
after his arrest
jones went on the pat mcafee show to
explain his side of the story
i can't really see exactly what was
going on in the back behind me because i
was talking to the dj
now the the bouncer dude came in like
everybody got to get the fuck out of
here
now remind you my dude just put them out
of the spot that we was in
last week before that yeah there's
almost like a revenge thing but
at the time i don't need here to do what
he's saying because i'm talking to the
dj
all right so they got whatever going on
he touched my my little brother
and when i turn around they already on
the float
so i i separate him and he said hey
y'all want to fight before you say my
y'all want to fight
that's when punches and chairs whatever
they was throwing and personally back
i'm done fighting bro like unless
somebody want to pay me i'm cool with it
i'll fight any celebrity
back for analysis as criminal defense
attorney eklund mercy and terry austin
terry kicked him punch until he was
unconscious is pac-man's explanation
good enough for you here actually brian
it's not i think he's lucky he's only
being charged with misdemeanor assault i
mean he's been involved in altercations
before
in tennessee you know he kicked and
punched a security guard he got in a
brawl in atlanta
he hit someone at this casino in indiana
i just think that he may have some
issues as far
as you know his physicality is
concerning he has to be careful because
he's a big guy and he could really hurt
someone so kicking someone in the head
until they're unconscious that's you
know it could have been
murder so i think he's very lucky he got
off with the misdemeanor assault
yeah equine defense of others is a
defense but it could have been a little
excessive here
when you heard that interview i
personally would have maybe told him
don't give that interview you might want
to shut your mouth because later on i
believe he actually says
i did what i had to do and that's kind
of frightening when you're talking about
such a big guy right
no and i i i honestly like the interview
to be real honest
because um celebrities especially
football players and ex-football players
do you know like how much he like how
much people just
get on him he actually explained that
this wasn't a one-time incident he's had
history with this
with this dude so when you have somebody
who is consistently trying to be
you know you have this man who is
consistently checked by people who are
not of his caliber
you know i'm saying you cannot get mad
if you lose a fight um he was protecting
his brother
um thank god everybody is alive but um
to say that it was his size don't you
know don't start none it won't
be none so i think that it was in a fray
instead of like just
him being you know he wasn't pummeled he
was security
so i mean if you can't be security
that's on you i actually think that um
he has a good case i think that it was a
good charge
we'll see how it goes thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily a
wisconsin murder trial heats up
as the defense attempts to point the
finger at someone else plus
remember the central park karen why the
case is now being dismissed
after the break
[Music]
charges have been dropped for a new york
woman captured on video
calling 9-1-1 on a black man in central
park
sorry i'm asking you to stop please
don't come close to me
sir i'm asking you to stop recording
please don't come close to me please
take your photo please don't come close
to me i'm taking your pictures
please please call the cops please call
the cops
i'm going to tell them there's an
african-american man threatening my life
please tell them whatever you like
i'm being threatened by a man into the
rambo please send the cops immediately
the case against amy cooper seen here
was dismissed after completing a
counseling program
prosecutors say they're pleased with her
participation which included five
educational and therapy classes
on racial equity the misdemeanor charge
of filing a false police report stemmed
from the may 25th incident
over cooper's unleashed dog cooper
called 9-1-1
saying that bird watcher chris cooper
had tried to assault her
the claim was not true chris and amy are
not related
here to discuss community service for
amy cooper is defense attorney eklyn
mercy and co-host terry austin
terry i can say this as a public
defender in new york
if this wasn't a high-profile case is it
is exactly how
most of my cases at least end actually
she might not have been charged if this
wasn't high profile so do you feel that
this case ended appropriately you know
brian i don't think it ended
appropriately i don't think counseling
is enough i know the judge
said that this was restorative justice
and
she needed to be educated on the harm of
her actions yes i agree with that but i
also think she should have done a little
bit of jail time because
she filed a false report and i think
there needs to be an example here this
could have ended so
very differently and i think we need to
make sure that others are
not going to do the same thing and think
that they can get off i i think she got
off easily
all right eclin what do you think is
this justice or does she get off easily
too easy maybe i
i actually think she got i i think it
was justice because mr cooper didn't
want to press charges
um he made that very clear but the
prosecutors went forth
and didn't let her off with just the you
know with just the slap on the wrist she
had to do the classes
i mean we cannot fix racism with just
one karen
um i'm shocked though she wasn't charged
with animal cruelty because it seems
like that
dog was being hurt pretty severely but i
i think that it justice was served
um we can't have her be a representative
of all
racists and i and i think that um mr
cooper's
uh unwillingness to really prosecute
actually just
i you know it came out to a good good
thing i mean
she didn't get a slap on the wrist she
had to take classes she had to be
inconvenienced
i don't think anybody will ever give her
a dog ever again
or you know everybody knows her from now
on i think the damage has been done with
regards to this case
yeah there could be non-criminal damage
from social media her name being put out
there i can see that as being
a form of punishment the prosecutor
would consider i i see that thank you
both
uh when we come back testimony in the
trial of a man charged in the murder of
his wife
eight years after she was reported
missing her son takes the stand
next
a wisconsin man is on trial for the
alleged murder of his wife of 24 years
prosecutors say he had the means and the
motive but they're still missing a body
victoria prokapovic was reported missing
on april 25th
2013. investigators are unable to find
her remains
but arrested her husband james
prokopovic in 2019
after they say he confessed to killing
her procopovich has since recanted and
says his wife was suicidal
the victim's son was living with them in
2013 and said the couple got into an
argument the night before
she disappeared i remember
uh confrontation about
uh jim not wanting to go to the dollar
store
for i believe it was a tablecloth
roughly around fiveish
they both seemed a little agitated he
didn't want to go
i believe his words were we can get it
later or tomorrow or something like that
and my mom would always complain to me
or tomorrow never comes
okay and did you see that that was
frustrating to your mom
yes now at the time that you're having
dinner do you remember if jim is
drinking any alcohol
yes what was he drinking a beer was
it common occurrence daily weekly
monthly that he would have a beer daily
investigators say they've ruled out
edges as a suspect because he has an
alibi
but on cross the defense pressed him
about possible inconsistencies in his
timeline
do you call what time that you left the
residence
6 30 somewhere in there do you recall
giving previous
testimony in a previous hearing that you
got a text message around 8
30 and you were still at your residence
at that time i don't recall that no
you went to your friend roslyn's house
to buy weed is that your understanding
yes did you smoke any wheat at that
house
yes do you know approximately what time
you
got to your friend ronson's house uh
that evening
probably 12 30 1 o'clock did you
immediately smoke weed or did you smoke
weed later in the evening later in the
evening
and you know approximately what time you
started that no
do you know approximately time you left
bronzman's house
3 30 4 o'clock and you testified
and they're direct that you got home
around 4 00 am yeah around 4 00 am
okay so around 4 am for you is between 4
and 4 30.
your honor i'm gonna object to relevance
your honor i'm just trying to get a
timeline here
i think he's entitled to a timeline when
you
got out of the truck you saw your father
and he said mom is gone yes
and you clarified it is what do you mean
she's gone and he says she's missing
correct you didn't say she's missing
what did he say specifically i woke up
and she's gone
okay back to break down the wisconsin
murder with no body is equine mercy and
terry austin
eckland a previous ruling says that the
defense can't point the finger
at the sun west edges that we saw
because of an alibi
but aren't they kind of sort of maybe
doing that anyways and shouldn't they be
allowed to
yeah they should absolutely be allowed
to as a criminal defense attorney i
am i have the right to a thorough and
sifting cross-examination
and i believe that alibis are a fact
question
that are reserved for the jury you
cannot take that away from the defense
you the defense requires justice so if
you know um he's already smoking we he
he's already on there
we have the right to impeach our
witnesses
and if his alibi sucks his alibi sucks
and
the defense has a right to attack it i
think that the
judge ruled wrong and should have
allowed them to be able to
point the finger at the sun
interestingly enough they actually
agreed to it which makes me really
curious why the defense would do that
now terry during the defense's cross
examination it was very interesting
he actually pulled out not from this
witness but the victim's sister
that the victim victoria had and i want
to make sure i get this right because i
was in the chat rooms with addie
and our viewers who watch the trial live
that she has dissociative identity
disorder
how did you feel that came out and how
can that be used in the defense's
arguments
you know i think the defense is doing a
great job here i think that
so far you heard one objection there but
that was from the prosecution i think so
far the defense is allowing most of this
information to get in to evidence
because he knows and he understands that
regardless of what you
call the you know mental illness that
it will help his case because it will
show that there was a tendency here
for the you know victim to have suicidal
thoughts et cetera so i think so far
most of this is helping the defense all
right we'll see how it goes as it
continues ekklen terry thank you
and thank you for joining us here along
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you